you put three thousand eight hundred
dollars in a savings account the bank
will provide one point eight percent
interest on the money in the account
every year another way of saying that
the money in the savings account will
grow by one point eight percent per year
write an expression that describes how
much money will be in the account in 15
years
so let's just think about this a little
bit let's just think about the starting
amount
so in the start we're just going to put
3 800
we could view that as year zero
year
actually let me write it that way so the
start
is the same thing as
year
zero
and we're going to start with three
thousand
eight hundred dollars
now let's think about year one
how much money will we have after one
year well we would have the original
amount that we put three thousand
eight hundred dollars
and then we're going to get the amount
that we get in interest and they say
that the bank will provide 1.8 percent
interest on the money in the account
so it'll be plus
1.8 percent
times
3 800.
30 our 3800 or 3 800
and we could also write this as a
decimal this is equal to 3
800 plus and i'll just write i'll switch
the order of multiplication here plus 3
800
times
zero point zero one eight one point
eight percent is the same thing as
eighteen thousandths or one point eight
hundredths depending on how you want to
pronounce it
and so here you might say well there's
kind of an interesting potential
simplification mathematically here i
could factor 3 800 out of each of these
terms i have a 3 800 here i have a 3 800
here so why don't i factor it out
essentially undistributed it so this is
going to be 3800
times when you factor it out here you
get a 1
plus when you factor it out here you get
0.018
and so i could just rewrite this as 3800
times 1.018
so this is a interesting time to pause
we're not at the full answer yet how
much we have in 15 years but we have an
interesting expression for how much we
have after one year notice that if the
money is growing by 1.8 percent or
another way it was growing by 0.018
that's equivalent to multiplying the
amount that we started the year with by
1 plus the amount that it's growing by
or
1.018 and once again why does this make
intuitive sense because at the end of
the year you're going to have the
original amount that you put that's what
that one really represents and then plus
you're going to have the amount that you
grew by so you multiply both the sum
here times the original amount you put
and that's how much you'll have at the
end of year one what about year two
so
year
two
well we know what we're going to start
with in year two we're gonna start with
whatever we finished year one with so
we're gonna start with 3 800
times
1.018
but then it's going to grow by 1.8
percent or grow by
0.018 and we already said if you're
going to grow by that amount that's
equivalent to multiplying it by 1.018
well this is the same thing as 3800
times
1.018 to the second power
i think you see where this is going
every time we grow by one point eight
percent we're going to multiply by 1.018
and if we're thinking about 15 years in
the future we're going to do that 15
times so one year in the future your
exponent here is essentially one two
years your exponent is two so year 15 i
can just cut to the chase here
so year
15
well that's just going to be we're going
to have the original amount that we
invested and we are going to grow 1.018
15 times so we're going to multiply by
this amount 15 times to get the final
amount and even and one of the fun
things this is actually called compound
growth where every year you grow on top
of the amount that you had before you'll
see if you type this into a calculator
that even though 1.8 percent per year
does not seem like a lot
over 15 years
it actually would amount to a reasonable
amount but this is the expression we
they're not asking us to calculate it
they just want us to know an expression
that describes how much money will be in
the account in 15 years